Four,
three,
two,
one.
Hello,
Michael.
Welcome.
Thanks man.
Thanks for doing this.
Thanks for coming in.
One hundred percent,
man.
People don't know the story.
Will Give them the brief synopsis.
I found out about your story online
because there was this viral thing that
was going on about a chef who was
getting protested by a bunch of animal
rights activists and Vegans who decided
to camp out in front of your business
and try to a restaurant called antler
and Toronto try to.
I don't know what the fuck they were
trying to do,
but you decided to butcher a a leg of
deer in front of them and it became this
horrific thing like how could you do
that and a place that serves meat.
How could you prepare the meat right in
front of them?
Like how did this all get started?
How did it become such a crazy viral
story and why?
Why were they mad at you when there's a
million other restaurants around you?
All right,
so it started in about December of a
clue.
Number one,
Canadian,
the crazy Canadian besides being nice,
but that's why
viral,
because I wasn't being nice.
I wasn't the stereotypical Canadian.
No,
you weren't even being mean.
You're just doing your job and doing my
thing.
So they started in December and they
really is right in front of your face.
They really got pissed off with our.
We have a little chalkboard sign out
front.
Um,
I'll give you the,
we have a 45 seat restaurant,
so we're a small,
uh,
have one business partner who's a,
my best friend and family friend.
And we had a little chalkboard sign out
front that said Venison is the new Kale
and you know,
we get cute with our sign.
We tease other restaurants around us
like we have fun with the sign and it's
fun.
And the cyclist Vegan rode by and took
huge offense to our sign and all of a
sudden one day these protesters just
showed up.
So I'm originally,
I was just kind of frustrated because
they're totally misguided because um,
we take a lot of pride in where our food
comes from.
We have Vegan and vegetarian dishes on
the menu.
And I really respect that type of diet,
so we were just totally floored with why
this was happening.
And so they started going,
they'd started come every week and they
went from like two or three people being
kind of peaceful to being like 10,
15 people,
not so peaceful.
So a is when it turned not so peaceful.
They were shouting at our,
at our guests and shouting in our door
and really trying to harm our business.
That,
uh,
I just kind of got fed up.
Last resort,
went down,
we get a whole deer a couple times a
month and we,
we butchered ourselves.
And uh,
I just said,
screw it,
screw it.
I'm like,
I'm going to get these people to get out
of here.
So I thought that that would
make them go away.
How did you think that was going to make
them go away and not escalate it?
Uh,
I don't know.
I was,
it was just totally like last resort,
a totally
fed up.
Um,
I wanted to defend myself,
defend our customers,
you know,
you could see people walking in visibly
upset,
um,
you know,
they're being shouted at being screamed
at,
called a murderer as they're walking in
for dinner,
like you're going on a date,
you want to have this time and then
people are screaming at you,
uh,
you know,
just for eating.
So,
uh,
I was just fed up and I just kinda
thought like,
you know,
buzz off and why.
So just one sign once I send is the new
Kale one sign set this whole thing off.
Yeah.
And you're surrounded by restaurants.
I mean,
I know where you are.
So we're surrounded by restaurants until
there's an actual butcher shop across
the street and if you go in,
there's like whole cattle hanging.
That's okay.
And the butcher shop,
you're a problem with your comparison to
Kale.
You attack their sacred tail.
We're promoting a meet.
I don't know,
that's really bizarre because you are
promoting and we were promoting it or
uh,
yeah.
So I just didn't promote anything and
they were allowed to cycle by and dream
of Broccoli without interference.
Yeah.
Man,
I have no idea.
It's totally bizarre.
I'm sorry,
how many times did they protest you?
Um,
I think it's about eight now.
Eight.
They're coming in weekly.
They still do.
There's one this Friday.
Oh Jesus.
So they organize,
they organize them.
There's like facebook groups,
there's a,
they're basically giving us an
ultimatum.
We have to put their slogan in our
window and they'll go away.
But yeah,
what's their slogan?
Um,
there's,
there's like,
I can't remember it word for word,
but it's,
you know,
like killing animals is wrong and they
have feelings while.
Yeah.
Do you have to put that in your window?
We don't,
we're not going to.
There's no way they want.
That's what they want.
Yeah.
So eco terrorism,
extortion,
wherever you want to call it.
Wow.
Well,
the part,
the part of this that drives you the
most crazy is the fact that you're
surrounded by restaurant.
We're surrounded by restaurants you're
surrounded by,
like you said,
you're across cross street from a
butcher shop.
90 seven percent of the people in the
world eat meat.
It's something,
something crazy like that.
I mean,
I'm sure everyone hasn't really been
pulled.
I'm sure it's not that accurate,
but it's somewhere between 95 and $97.
It's big.
And I think we know we're an easy
target,
you know,
her name is antler.
We were,
I think they're mad because,
um,
you know,
their,
their thing is that we're promoting
ethical farming and their beliefs is
there is no such thing as ethical
farming that all meat is murder.
And um,
you know,
if you look up murder in the dictionary,
it has to do with humans,
you know,
it has nothing to do with animals.
And um,
there is such a thing as ethical farming
and sustainable farming and we work
really hard to make sure that where we
get our meat from,
his,
uh,
from the best possible place we can and
it's local.
So it's supporting our local farmers
that are within hours of our restaurant.
Now,
when you say that they started out nice
like how many people were there in the
beginning?
Two,
three,
four.
And they had signs and they were just
kind of,
you know,
promoting their message,
but they weren't really yelling and
screaming and what escalated it.
Um,
so we would call the police.
We kind of got wind of it on their
facebook groups,
so we would call the police and have the
police there to make sure everyone's
safe because one thing like customers
are scared,
our staffers scared.
Like,
no one's dealt with this before.
I've never dealt with this before.
Um,
so we would have the police there they
were,
the police were amazing.
Um,
and then one time we kind of,
okay,
let's not call the police,
let's see what happens.
Maybe it'll just,
they'll go away.
And so then like a megaphone came out,
uh,
our neighbors were coming down and
getting in fights with them.
And it was,
it was ugly.
So we called the police to come and
Jesus Christ keeps the peace.
Yeah.
A megaphone.
Part of the problem with these kinds of
things is it becomes a contest,
becomes a battle,
you know,
trying to see who's gonna win.
And they're absolutely on a team.
I mean,
this,
that's one of the things that happens
with veganism and I think it happens
with hunters to,
excuse me,
people become very tribal,
you know,
and you know,
it's us versus them and they want to win
and then it becomes this thing where,
you know,
look,
the reality is a lot of people are
idiots and they don't have a lot going
on in their life.
And so when something comes up where it
becomes a primary focus of their life,
one restaurant is a logical is,
it might be that becomes the battle
ground and it's an ideological battle
ground for,
you know,
don't eat meat ever versus sustainable
farming.
You know,
this the look,
I'm sure,
I know you're a hunter,
I'm sure you feel a certain amount of
remorse when an animal dies a hundred
percent.
That's a big part of sort of my beliefs
and my philosophy and why I'm working on
this cookbook right now is because,
uh,
I think that if you do eat meat,
you should be able to kill an animal and
experience that.
And I,
I think that if people were to actually
kill an animal,
they would see,
you know,
what goes into that and I don't think
people would consume as much,
meaning I don't think people would
definitely,
certainly wouldn't waste as much meat as
they do and it's just really upsetting.
And I think it's totally misguided.
You know,
why we were targeted.
Well,
I mean,
like I said,
I think it just becomes a game.
Yeah.
It becomes a big tribal game.
You know,
there's,
there's a real argument,
a real argument that I support against
factory farming and factory farming is
the way most people are getting their
meat in terms of like in terms of like
cheeseburgers and fast food and stuff
along those lines.
I mean,
you're not getting it from the most
ethical sources.
It's just not financially sustainable to
do it that way.
Everything would cost more money.
Yep.
And,
uh,
that's a real.
That we,
as a society,
it's not obviously not you or I that set
up the system,
but that this system is a system that we
find ourselves a part of.
It's a real problem.
I've removed myself from it for the most
part,
but occasionally I'm on the road and I'm
hungry and you know,
I'll eat some meat.
That's just whatever.
Totally.
It's,
it's a necessary evil,
you know,
in sort of sorts.
It's not really necessary at all that
maybe that's the wrong way to describe
it,
but it's how the system has been set up
and it's,
it's actually why I started hunting and
doing what I do because I watched these
documentaries like food inc and these
things that kind of shine a light on,
you know,
the system and how this stuff is
actually being produced.
And it's horrible.
It's a,
it's terrible.
Yes.
Yeah.
And I think that's the real number one
problem and you know,
and this Vegan activist message to go
after these types of farming,
you know,
we support as well.
We agree with.
So the fact that we were targeted for
this was really,
really frustrating.
Yeah.
I think vegans,
um,
I understand where they're coming from,
but I don't think that they have seen
the big picture.
And the big picture is there's some
animals that need to be harvested.
They're not sustainable.
Wild pigs is the best example.
There is no way you are going to stop
wild pigs without killing them.
There's no way.
You're not going to give them birth
control.
You're not going to,
unless you've gotta let loose fucking
packs of wolves.
And I mean packs to deal with like
what's going on in Texas.
I mean,
they,
they're forced to shoot them out of
helicopters.
They hot crazy.
They hire people to come in with
helicopters and shoot them from this
guy.
It's that bad.
And this is farmers.
There's companies called Hella hunting
where they have it on the side,
like they have a wild boar and a fucking
helicopter blade on their logo.
They have to do it.
Yeah,
know.
And I,
I don't,
I don't have a lot of experience with
that because where I am,
we don't have that wild boar problem.
But uh,
I,
I hunt with these guys from,
from Moscow yoke and I've gone down
there and done one of these pig hunts
and they've shown me their fields and
like one third of their cornfield is
just destroyed,
destroyed.
And they have to hunt them at night or
they hunt them with dogs and uh,
it's a huge problem for farmers trying
to make a living.
It is a huge problem.
And vegans themselves need to understand
that's your food supply.
Totally.
You're not growing your own food.
Mostly.
Most people listening to this that are
Vegan or not growing their own food.
You're getting your own food from a
farm.
That farm is getting attacked by pigs.
That's the only one animal.
The other one is dear.
I mean there's a shitload of deer in
North America.
What's interesting is California has a
very weird way of handling it and I kind
of get it in some ways.
The weird way that we handle it in
California is we don't hunt mountain
lions.
Okay.
There's no mountain lion hunting.
This is very few deer.
I mean,
I see deer in my neighborhood.
I've lived in a fairly rural area.
Yup.
I see deer,
you know,
couple of times a week.
But it's nothing like if you go to the
east coast,
have you ever been in the east coast of
California or the United States?
Like New York state,
that kind of area,
but near New York City.
I had been to the east coast.
Now the state,
if you go upstate like New York state,
there's so many fucking deer up there.
It's one of the reasons why lyme disease
is so horrible up there.
It's comes from the ticks that were on
the deer and people get these terrible,
terrible cases of lyme disease and it's
fucking everywhere up there,
man.
I have several friends that have really
bad lyme disease.
Have to take 'em,
go to Jim Miller's instagram.
Jim Miller is a fighter in the UFC,
a high level fighter who's been
competing at the highest level for a
long time and he has serious lyme
disease to the point where it's
debilitating,
it's scary.
He has to take a fat bag of pills and he
held up his pills the other day.
What he takes while he's looking at this
is what he takes wally's in training
camp.
That's insane.
Nineteen days of medication supplements.
He said,
he said,
fuck Lee.
Me Thirty one capsules a day.
You do the math.
Remember the carry to seven a and it
just says lyme disease is one of the
hashtags.
Yeah,
he's got it really bad and I mean,
what's crazy is the guy could not be
healthier,
works out,
constantly eats right.
He's not booze and his body's just
falling apart because of fucking lyme
disease and it's being carried by these.
These deer overpopulation of wild
animals is handled in one of two ways.
Either you introduced predators or you
manage them with hunting.
Um,
there's a place in Maui,
in Maui where they are,
um,
the at Maui has no predators,
you know,
and,
but they also have a bunch of wild game
that was brought in for King Kamehameha,
I think it was in the 18 hundreds.
They brought it in,
I'm not sure when,
but there's tons of access deer on,
on Maui and Lanai and on Molokai and a
couple of different islands.
And one of the things they've started
doing is they were trying to figure out
how to eradicate them from this area.
So a bunch of hunters got together and
they're hunting these access deer.
Then giving the meat to poor people.
Like making it free for them and it's a,
it's a really cool program,
but that's another sort of situation
where you kind of have to hunt you.
There's no other,
unless you're just going to poison them
or you're going to somehow or another
capture them all and neuter and spay a
certain amount of them every month.
There's really no other way to handle
it.
Yeah.
And I think that's a big misconception
that people that don't educate
themselves about hunting,
hunting is bad.
Killing animals is bad and they'd get on
this bandwagon but they don't have
enough information about it know.
Um,
and I think people confuse trophy
hunting with like they see cecil the
lion and everyone goes after,
okay,
it's hunting is the,
is the problem,
but,
you know,
trophy hunting is the problem.
But the hunters that hunt for food and
that hunt to help the,
uh,
the sort of environmental impacts that
they're having.
Like people don't like snow geese.
I don't know if you know much about
snow.
You read that article that you
retweeted.
Actually,
yeah.
They like a nat Geo article that I
posted these birds fly in flocks of 20,
30,000
birds and they land in a farmer's field
and they eat everything,
everything and they destroy it and you
know,
like 10,
15 years ago these populations of birds,
they weren't like they are now.
So I'm well large scale agriculture is
also responsible for the boom and the
population of deer,
deer and in America,
particularly like in the midwest where
all the farms are.
What is it a fucking coincidence that
there's all the deer were all the farms
are?
No,
it's not by my good friend Doug Darren,
he has a big ass farm in Wisconsin.
Beautiful place in the driftless area.
Do you know what that is?
It's where the glaciers didn't pass
through,
so it's not flat.
It was all these hills and it's very
beautiful and lakes.
It's a phenomenal place,
but essentially he's got the deer that
he hunts and that,
that he and his friends hunt on his
property.
They're farm animals.
Totally.
Corn grows corn.
He's a farmer,
so he grows all this corn.
The deer are eating all this corn and
they're fucking delicious.
Man.
They're huge.
They're so good.
But there's a reality to a population
control.
Now in Wisconsin,
they get it because they're around them
every day.
They're hitting them with their cars.
They see them everywhere.
They look.
There's,
this is not like the idealistic view of
someone who lives in a city street in
Toronto and is driving around their bike
looking for signs that are criticizing
Kale or whatever the fuck they're doing.
They're not in the real natural world
that these animals are present.
They don't get it.
They don't understand,
uh,
you know,
they live in their bubble and you know,
another thing they don't understand is
that hunter is actually,
you know,
we have to buy tags.
We have to buy our licenses that were
rules and laws that we have to follow.
And those fees actually pay for the
wildlife conservation.
And I'm pretty sure it's the same in the
states as well from talking to my
friends and it is Pitman Robertson Act
and they don't understand been percent
of all the proceeds from hunting gear go
to wildlife conservation.
And that turns out to be billions and
billions of dollars.
It's far more than any other
conservation group,
far more than any wildlife conservation
group or animal activist group,
and no one contributes more to
conservation than hunting because we
want.
We want it to be there for our kids and
their kids and it's nature.
It's,
it's how the world is supposed to be.
It's also this contradictory thing that
seems.
It seems like it doesn't make sense,
but we love the wildlife.
I love the animals.
Just because you eat them doesn't mean
you don't love them,
but you recognize them as.
This is a weird way to look at it,
but it is a renewable resource.
Right?
And it is also a magical,
beautiful thing.
Just because of that doesn't mean you
shouldn't eat it.
Yeah,
I mean it's this,
this disconnect that people have with
the wild,
I think is a real part of it.
A real part of the problem.
Good luck finding a Vegan in Alaska.
You know,
there's not a whole lot of them that
live out in the bush that are vegans,
salmon and they're eating and you can,
you can bring in vegetables.
I mean,
I'm sure there are some of them just
talking shit,
but the reality is if you're,
if you're embedded in that world,
you understand it and you appreciate it
and it's very humbling.
I mean,
killing an animal is very humbling.
it sounds like somewhat as an animal
lover,
that sounds fucking crazy.
It's hard.
It's also really hard.
Like when I see a deer come out,
I hunt with a bow crossbow and I see a
deer come out.
It's,
I'm trembling.
The hair on my back is standing up.
There are these beautiful,
majestic creatures and I'm going to kill
it and it's really,
really difficult and I don't think that
people understand that,
that don't hunt and then haven't killed
an animal.
They don't understand the respect and
the amount of effort that goes into
that.
No,
they definitely don't,
but they don't care.
I mean,
what they have an idea and the is
animals should not die,
but they're going to die.
It's,
they're going to die of old age.
They're going to die of starvation.
They're gonna freeze to death.
They're gonna,
they're gonna be eaten alive.
They're going to be eaten alive,
and people think that animals,
they die peacefully in the wild.
It's absolutely incorrect.
If you google anything about how animals
dying well and they're being eaten
alive,
like deer being taken down and eaten
alive by wolves or coyotes or whatever
it is,
there's bears and it's horrific.
And to be shot with an Arrow to be shot
with a bullet,
it's a way more humane way to go,
uh,
in my,
in my opinion,
oh,
it's unquestionably a more humane way to
go.
I mean,
it's one of the reasons why I hunt and I
practiced so much.
I practice every day.
I have one of the reasons why we got
this building,
so I could put a $45 dollars.
I want to shoot it to practice.
Well,
we could shoot afterwards,
but I was have to fucking practice.
You have to be,
you have to be able to make an ethical
shot,
but now when I sit down and I cook
something for my family,
I know where that came from.
If we have vegetables that we grow in
our garden,
there's a great satisfaction for serving
up some cucumbers or some,
some Kale or whatever it is that we grow
in our garden.
It tastes better when you.
When you go out there and you cut that
cucumber off the planet and you cut that
Kale down,
it is like half an hour old,
like nothing compares to that freshness
that you go to the grocery store that
may be a couple of days a week,
a month old.
You have no idea and for me as a chef,
that's why I love hunting and foraging
and having a garden in my backyard
because when you go and pick something,
nothing tastes as good as that.
Right?
Yeah.
I mean I appreciate were vegans and
animal rights activists are coming from
because it's coming from.
I think there's a lot of distortion with
like really angry ones,
but this is my take on a lot of this is
you get a group of 100 people,
one of them for sure is a fucking idiot
just out of just sheer odds,
right?
Like what are the odds?
One of them is a fucking gets pretty
strong,
right?
Well if you're going to get a group of
100 vegans,
you're going to get at least one of
them.
That's fucking idiot.
And they're going to be.
Some of them are violent,
some of them are super aggressive about
it.
I mean there's a ton of them online.
You can go.
They.
Their identity is completely wrapped
around veganism.
These vegan in their name,
it's always,
I'm the Vegan this or the Vegan that
that is 100 percent of their name,
so a 100 percent of their identity,
so they can't.
They can't separate from it ever.
Like that is who they are forever and
they have been some serious problems.
What was the name of that cafe again?
Cafe gratitude.
There were some people that were running
a Vegan restaurant,
I think they have a couple of them right
in La and um,
they were having health issues and some
people,
the Vegan Diet just doesn't agree with
them and maybe they were doing it wrong,
maybe they have unique dietary needs,
but they started raising cattle and they
started eating those cattle and the
fucking vegans freaked out.
Death threats,
all this crazy shit coming after them
protesting.
And,
you know,
these people were terrified.
They're older folks,
they're,
you know,
they're elderly.
They're,
it is Vegan restaurant owners received
death threats over animal slaughter
scandal.
Yeah,
I mean this is the bad ones,
right?
And it's not,
most of them,
most vegans I think are vegans for all
the right reasons.
You're misinformed if you choose to,
to not,
uh,
to not eat meat and choose that kind of
lifestyle like power to.
It's amazing.
And I think that it,
you know,
if,
if it works for you in your body,
that's great.
And for me it doesn't work for me.
Like I've,
I've done Vegan cleanses,
I've done the juice cleanses,
I've,
I've done,
I've gone out for,
as a chef to Vegan restaurants and I'm
not full,
you know,
I'll,
I'll eat three or four courses,
I'll spend tons of money and half an
hour later I'm starving,
starving and I need to eat something
with protein and lots of protein and
it's meat or fish or I've made tofu from
scratch,
from soybeans and it's just,
it doesn't,
it's not the same.
Yeah.
Well right now people are screaming,
you're doing every vegan food is tasty,
but I'm not selling of it is.
Some of it's good.
I mean,
I eat vegan raw all the time there.
There's a Vegan restaurant near me.
I go to all the time.
Sometimes you get dirty looks,
this motherfucker's here.
Why are you here?
You're not allowed to.
You're not one of us.
You're not allowed to eat our food.
Um,
it's just,
it's very unfortunate that I think these
ideological groups get tainted by the
most extreme members.
And I think that's true on the hunting
side too.
And you got guys like fucking Ted
Nugent,
you know,
and all the people that I think that
they distort the real sort of
fascinating in mystical qualities of
wildlife and harvesting wildlife and
being out there and experiencing nature.
It said it's an almost psychedelic
experience to to,
to hunt and be in the wild.
That sounds so counterintuitive to
someone who's never experienced it,
but the world of these animals,
when you're away from your cell phone,
when you're away from television and all
the bullshit and the computer,
when you're.
When you're out there in the wild,
you are almost in another dimension.
If you're in complete silence in the
forest,
in you,
your mind goes into a completely
different sort of mode that is familiar,
but yet alien.
It's familiar in a way that your body's
like,
oh,
this is hunting.
This is what humans have done for
hundreds of thousands of years.
This is why we became human.
I mean,
this is literally one of the reasons
that scientists believed that our brains
grew is because we started eating meat.
We started cooking meat.
The nutrition became more accessible and
also we started thinking about how to
hunt,
developing tools to hunt with.
I mean all of this is the reason why
humans are humans today and I'm sure the
Vegan argument against that would be,
well,
that's then and we're past that now.
While we're not.
No,
we're not.
We're not.
Because of controlling the population of
animals,
we're certainly not because of
controlling the population of predators
and that's another thing that people
need to accept and understand.
There's a reason why they eradicated all
the wolves in North America before they
reintroduced them to yellowstone and now
they're thriving and many parts of the
northwest,
it's because they were fucking killing
everything and there's.
They don't have any predators and the
predators that they have are humans,
and if we don't keep the populations in
check of them and have grizzly bears
have black bears and all the other
predators,
they start eating each other.
They start tearing each other apart.
They start coming after us to start
encroaching on p.
well,
we're in their territory.
We shouldn't be in their place.
We humans.
Incredible.
Look,
I'm on team people so I don't know what
the fuck you're saying here.
You're saying that we should move out of
San Francisco and give it to the wolves.
You can go fuck yourself.
Right,
and this is literally what it boils down
to because you have to draw some line in
the sand somewhere because if someone
doesn't control the population of
animals,
then what's going to happen?
Well,
you know,
you can leave them to their own devices
and they can sort of sort it out,
but you know how they sorted out through
disease and starvation.
I mean what happens is there's too many
animals and not enough food.
So they get horrific diseases.
That's where mange comes from.
That's where a lot of serious diseases
that infect wildlife come from.
They come from a lack of food or
overpopulation.
That's how nature sorts it out,
you know?
And that's how nature sorts of that with
people too.
Which just sneaky.
We've used vaccines and shit and we're
at the top of food chain.
We've worked hard to get there.
We are and I think we it comes with a
certain responsibility and that
responsibility is really.
We were really doing a disservice to
that responsibility with factory farming
and that's one of the main arguments for
veganism that one of the main arguments
is the horrific treatment of those
animals,
whether it's veganism or or or or
whether it's rather factory farming or
whether it's a large skill,
dairy farms where they mistreat their
cows or the chicken farms are all these
different factory farms with a treat
these animals not as a living being but
as a commodity.
Then it becomes a giant problem.
But if you look at guys like,
do you know Joel Salitan is Joel South,
tends very fascinating guy.
He runs a farm called polyface farms and
what he is essentially done is made
large scale animal agriculture possible
in a humane and very natural way.
He has enormous electric fences that he
uses for his pigs and he just moves them
around,
moves the fences around so the pigs
wander around.
Here's a huge rolling chicken coop.
I mean it's fucking huge and he pushes
that thing around.
He moves it to a new space,
the chickens go out,
they wander around and blah,
blah,
blah.
They do the chicken thing and they go
right back into the chicken house and
this is where it gets the eggs from.
This is how they raised chickens.
This is how they raise cattle.
They do it with all these different
animals and his perspective on all this
is that if you.
If you do it right,
it's not horrific.
It's not an evil thing,
and that these animals are living the
way they've.
They're meant to live.
Right,
and that's why.
That's one of the things that we do at
Antler is to,
is to find those farmers and guys like
that.
One of the farms that we get our deer
from,
they have thousand acres.
The deer roam as they pleased they're
eating,
not an apples and acorns and grass and
everything they're supposed to eat and
then when it's time they're,
they're collected and harvested and
that.
That is where we get our meat from and
we try really hard not to buy from these
facts.
We don't serve chicken,
beef or pork.
We have bison pheasant duck well bore
because these game farms,
they don't have these massive large
scale operations and I buy direct from
the farmer and they can tell me what
their diet is,
you know,
they're good months,
they're bad months.
We know all about these animals that
we're bringing to the restaurant and,
and you know,
we're really proud of that.
I have an,
an issue with people that keep saying
wild boar.
Why did they say wild boar when it's
wild pig.
So if it's a male,
it actually is a different breed.
So the pigs that are in these factory
farms or even regular regular pigs,
there's,
there's many different breeds and a lot
of them are hybrid.
Hybrid breeds.
The wild boar breed has long black hair
and tusks that actually come out so I
can buy whole pigs and they don't have
those tusks.
And when I buy the well bore breed,
the meat is darker,
hair is black,
but we're,
we're getting um,
you know,
there's no hair by the time we get them
and they've got the tusks in the jaw.
Right.
But my point is that a board is a male,
right?
You definitely eating females too.
That's true.
Yeah.
So why do call it a wild boar?
Because it's just.
Yeah,
it's just the breed.
But do you know that they're all the
same breed?
I did not know that.
All [inaudible] is the,
the,
I guess the genus,
is that what you say?
They're all sort of interchangeable
breed with each other.
I do know there's,
there's tons of different varieties like
the Berkshire,
there's Tamworth,
there's all these different kinds of
shorts.
Breeds of hogs is variations.
Yeah.
But they're all the same animal.
What's crazy about wild pigs is you took
a domestic pig,
you know,
like babe release babe out into the
forest.
They morph right a very short amount of
time.
Now it extends.
Their hair becomes darker and thicker.
Their tusks lengthen.
Interesting.
It's very weird.
There are weird animal.
Pigs are a weird animal because where
we're at a weird animal when they're
domestic,
they're sweethearts.
Unless you fall in the cage when they're
hungry and they fucking eat you,
which is crazy.
It's one of the main ways that farmers
die falling into cages that eaten by.
Some happens all the time.
It does.
It happens every year.
Guy will fuck up and fall into a pig pen
and the pigs just fuck him up.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Especially if you're dealing with those
really enormous pigs mean those pigs
need a lot of food and they're fucking
big and once they start chewing you,
that's your ass is just an aside.
Have you been pig hunting?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I've been hunting.
I've shot a couple of pigs.
Yeah.
The meat is definitely different.
It's a lot darker.
Darker.
Yeah.
It's delicious though.
And um,
where I do it.
What's really interesting is in
California,
a lot of the pigs were introduced by
William Randolph hearst,
that crazy asshole that ran from the
movie citizen Kane,
of course in wells depiction of him.
He was this crazy guy that ran hearst
publications in the 19 thirties.
He's literally one of the reasons why
marijuana is illegal.
Right?
William Randolph hearst decided that
when there was a cover of a believe as
popular science magazine that said hemp
is the new billion dollar crop,
and they were,
they had invented a machine called the
decorticator and when a decorticator
does is it effectively processes hemp
fiber.
I'm much more efficiently and for the
longest time they use slaves to process
hemp fiber,
but then Eli Whitney came around with
the cotton gin and they switch from hemp
clothing to cotton.
Cotton is easier to produce with the
cotton gin,
but it's just an inferior cloth.
Hamp makes better paper.
A hemp makes cloth.
You could make houses with it.
Henry Ford made the first fenders for
the first model t out of hemp.
I mean,
that's a crazy thing.
William Randolph hearst read this
article,
saw what was coming and realized that he
was going to have to transition all of
his paper mills and he owned forest,
that they would cut down the trees and
make paper with.
They will have to transition those to
hemp if people were demanding hemp.
So instead he undercut the entire
industry by saying that there was a new
drug that blacks and were smoking
and they were raping white women and he
called this drug marijuana,
which was really just the name of them.
It was a Mexican slang for wild tobacco.
So we start printing these stories.
Congress made it illegal.
They didn't even thought of people that
were voting on it,
didn't even know that they were making
cannabis or hemp,
the,
the textile.
And the commodity.
Him,
they didn't know they were making it
illegal.
They thought they were stopping a drug
scourge that was forcing blacks and
Mexicans to rape white women.
It was all William Randolph hearst is
one crazy asshole with Harry anslinger
in the fucking 19 thirties.
That's when it became illegal.
Well,
this is the same crazy asshole.
Let a bunch of wild pigs loose on his
property so he can hunt them because he
was a gentlemen hunter.
So the pigs that I hunt in California,
when I go pig hunting probably are
direct descendants from the pigs that
were let loose by this asshole.
And I think a lot of people don't
understand is how fast they breed.
Um,
you know,
my,
my friends and Mississippi were telling
me,
you know,
a pig can lay a litter three times a
year,
four times a year up to 10,
12 piglets per litter,
and they have no natural predators.
So what are these farmers going to do?
And they start decimating their crops.
Yeah.
They're not a native North American
species.
No.
Yeah.
And it's,
uh,
it's one of the most destructive
invasive species.
And if you,
if you've never seen them before,
you see them on tv,
they look,
you know,
it's a pig.
Pigs are cute.
I've seen my friend has a potbelly pit.
I pet it.
That's great.
What they are as adults,
when they're wild boars covered in mud
and disease,
they're fucking a mammal.
Plague.
They're vicious.
And they,
they go through everything.
They will spread across the country.
They'll destroy your garden that still
eat your dog.
I mean,
no bullshit.
They're fucking dangerous.
There's a lot of farmers actually asked
me if I'll come hunt on their property.
A lot of vineyards will ask me to come
in and they have a problem with the
Turkeys.
The Turkeys are eating all their grapes,
you know,
stuff like that,
that,
you know,
a lot of these,
a lot of regular kind of city people
live in the city that don't understand.
Yeah.
The Turkey population.
Some places are exploding too because
they've realized that it was just go to
the suburbs.
I even hunts us.
There was one running down the street in
Toronto last week at Turkey.
People were filming it and sending me
the.
Wow.
See?
Yeah,
they're delicious too.
that's actually the first bird I hunted.
I didn't actually start hunting until I
was in my twenties and I had grown up
cooking.
Um,
I was interested in becoming a chef and
a family friend told me he was going
Turkey hunting and I said,
well,
what do you mean you're going Turkey
hunting?
Like I thought Turkeys were.
I didn't know there was such thing as
well.
Turkey,
I thought they were a domesticated bird,
like a chicken.
So he takes me Turkey hunting and um,
I actually,
I couldn't believe it.
We,
you know,
we shot a couple of birds,
um,
you know,
we plucked them out and then the skin
was yellow and the meat is dark,
like,
like the chicken leg meat is like the
breast,
like it's dark and I just thought like,
wow,
this is incredible.
And then when I tasted it,
I just couldn't believe that this is
what Turkey was supposed to taste,
like blessed flavor and you grow up,
you know,
at least I grew up,
Christmas,
thanksgiving,
these,
these important holidays,
eating Turkey and you see it and it's
this big white blob and it's humongous.
And then,
you know,
the wild bird,
it's leaner.
It's not like super round.
It's,
it's,
it's lean,
it's how it's supposed to be in there.
For me,
that was like the light bulb moment that
this is what we're supposed to be
eating.
We're not supposed to be eating that
shit.
Yeah,
that shit that,
that really white meat,
Turkey,
look at them.
Here's the Turkey,
Toronto,
Toronto running down the street.
I'm so thankful to be here because it's
still snowing and so it's still snowing
and I,
I love winter and snowboarding and going
out and enjoying the snow,
but I'm done.
California.
Come on down.
Yeah man.
I was talking to a buddy of mine from
Montana on the phone yesterday.
It was fucking freezing cold up there.
Thick snow everywhere and you know,
they're about to open up their bear
season and he's like,
Jesus Christ.
It's snow's everywhere.
And I'm like,
dude,
I'm in my underwear right now outside.
I love it here man.
I have a soft spot for a for California.
I've been,
I've been coming here since I was a
little kid to visit my dad in the
summers and I come here two,
three times a year and I love it.
I love it too.
Uh,
you know,
the mountain lion thing is a weird thing
with California because I see their
point.
What would they be,
is essentially done is.
And this is one of the weird things
about California is like California is
one of the places that doesn't have a
fishing game department.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like they don't call it that,
call it wildlife,
they don't call it like a,
like they don't think of it as like you
have to hunt them.
Like if you say like fishing game or
Arizona calls it game and fish because
there's more game in Arizona and there
are fish desert.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting way they've
switched it around,
but I think the way California calls it,
it's fish and wildlife,
so we call it the Ministry of natural
resources.
That's a good way to look at it,
but you know,
I can't argue with the effectiveness of
their approach because you do not find a
lot of deer in California and deer
hunters are extremely frustrated by that
and I get it.
If you're like a local guy and you want
to be able to hunt your own deer,
it's hard going,
man.
It's crazy.
I actually didn't know there was hunting
here.
I had no idea and through through
hanging out with my friends at Mtsu
Yolk,
I met this guy that lives actually in
Orange County is named Jeremiah Dowdy
from field to plate.
If you don't know,
if you know this guy,
he's a local,
uh,
you know,
La guy and he hunts all over California.
I had no idea that there was so much
hunting.
California unt,
he's a really good friend of mine and
I'm saying,
well,
what's the.
He's like,
well,
there's Turkey.
There's wild pig.
There's the pronghorn.
There's all kinds of stuff that you can
hunt.
Yeah.
Today there's rocky mountain elk near to
home ranch,
and then there's two Lee elk that are
natural on the coast.
There's a lot of different animals here,
but there's also a lot of motherfucking
mountain lions.
Whoa.
And they still kill it,
but the way they kill them now is
through government trackers.
It's really kind of crazy.
What they do is mountain lion
starting people's dogs and cats and they
get the get scary and then people call
one of the,
I don't know who you would call that
would take care of it.
And they hire people and most of the
time they use dogs,
these dogs to tree the mountain lion and
they shoot them and when they empty the
contents,
their stomachs,
when they do an autopsy on them,
they find it filled with dogs and cats,
which is really kind of crazy.
There was one near my where my dad
lives.
A lady was attacked and they were
running a pair.
A pair of girls are running a in the
canyon and a mountain lion actually
attacked one of them and she was like
having a tug of war with the mountain
lion,
like with her friend.
So I think it was about five or six
years ago.
And that was this summer in Orange
County.
Someone was attacked,
running or cycling or something like
that.
Yeah.
And they had.
They had to.
They went and found it and shot it.
But
it's.
Well when they get hungry,
no wait,
we're encroaching because we're
encroaching on their land.
No,
it's just land.
Yeah.
It's not there as you.
Fuck.
This is what's crazy about.
People were encroaching on their
territory.
They're dead.
And then whatever was there that claim
that territory is dead,
and then there's a new one that comes
along and they take it.
There's a fucking constant battle.
This idea that like we're in their
community,
like they have a good established gated
community that we've entered and we
start putting up houses and pissing off
their neighbors.
No,
that's not what it is.
It's just land.
And if you hate people and you don't
like,
cities will then go fucking live in the
forest until then,
fuck off and stop saying like,
we're encroaching on their leg.
Do you go to the supermarket?
Yes.
Do you buy your Vegan food?
A Vegan Deli?
Well,
that's a place where a deer could have
lived.
Okay.
Do you go to the movie theater you do
while you piece of shit that used to be
like a Squirrel's house?
That was a field at one point.
Yeah,
I mean the large scale agriculture.
This is the other thing that kind of
drives me crazy about vegans.
It's not,
I'm not saying you shouldn't eat grain,
not saying you shouldn't eat vegetables,
but large scale agriculture in terms of
just raising vegetables is responsible
for a tremendous amount of death.
First of all,
there's the pesticides that they use
that kill bugs and now if you only like
mammals and you don't mind when people
kill bugs,
that seems a little hypocritical to me.
Gets a little weird but does get weird
and then there's the fact that when
you're making these,
when you're using a combine,
running through the,
all the rabbits,
all the bunnies,
all the hogs are being decimated.
Decimated.
My good buddy lives in Iowa and you
know,
he takes pictures.
He's like,
look,
we just chopped down.
We just cut the field,
look at all the vultures and the
vultures just circling overhead and
landing in the field right out.
They know when the combine rolls
through,
they come in dinner time.
They literally know.
It's like there's places in Alaska,
especially on Kodiak island where a
rifle shots equal.
I've heard of this dinner bell,
the forebears come running.
I've heard of this.
This is crazy.
Stairs
are are carrying like big magnum 45.
It's like pistols
to defend themselves against these
grizzlies.
I'll send you a fantastic podcast that.
Do you know Steven Rinella is?
No.
Steven Rinella is a really,
really interesting guy and he's a host
of a TV show called mediator.
He's just.
Oh yes,
yes,
yes.
He's an author.
He has a podcast that he recorded when
they were in a fog neck island,
which is like one of those chains of
islands near Kodiak,
so it has those enormous coastal brown
bears just like Kodiak.
And they got attacked.
They got attacked when they shot an elk
and they were packing the elk out and
they got rushed by a fucking tanker of a
bear and it is a crazy podcast because
they record it right after the fact
whenever everyone's freaking out still.
And you know,
one guy had a pistol on him but he set
it down next to his pack and they had
all these ideas of like what it would be
like if an animal came in.
Like if they got attack.
They had all these preconceived notions
of what it would be like.
What it would feel like.
It was like,
throw all that out the window.
It was you were in.
Your brain isn't not even on a reptilian
level.
Your brain is so terrified.
And this thing was so big.
My friend has said that he saw its teeth
gnashing literally feet from his head as
it ran through the candle.
My,
the revenant is just like,
fuck.
I got rushed by a deer one time and uh,
I was losing it.
I didn't know what to do.
It was a,
it was before sunrise.
It was like five in the morning.
I'm walking into my dear setup and I had
to cross this little river and it was
full of stones and stuff and I'm kinda
walking up this river and all I hear is
I put it on and I'm like,
Whoa,
like what the hell is that noise?
And then it stopped and it was pawing at
the ground and snorting.
And I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is a buck.
And like my,
my,
I got goosebumps right now thinking
about this and this is my bows in my bag
and I'm just like,
I'm going to get taken down by this
deer.
And then I thought it was another buck
because it's,
you know,
it's in the,
it's running season for these deer and
it then it smelt that I was a human and
it did that.
I got blown it,
whistled did that whistling,
blowing kind of sound and took off.
But I thought I was fucked.
I was like,
this is it.
Get gored.
I'm going to get gored by these antlers.
And that's it.
It was.
So,
yeah,
that was in Canada.
So I have,
those are big animals.
They're big.
We have big white tail and I'm 300
pounds sometimes they're big.
We and even our dozer,
huge like we got,
we got a lot of doe tags where I grew up
in a,
in Collagen,
which is about an hour north of the city
on a horse farm.
We don't have a gun season for deer.
So that's how I got into archery and
hunting with a bow.
That's interesting.
Why is that?
Um,
you know what,
I don't know.
I think it's because it's,
it's uh,
the farms are kind of closer together.
It's sort of like,
you know,
it's not huge agriculture.
They're more kind of hobby farm,
so I think they're a little closer
together,
letting loose bullets let loose bolts.
The main thing is rifles,
so a deer season and Turkey season you
can use a shotgun and it's really stupid
because you can,
you can shoot too with,
with a rifle or shotgun,
but there's no a shotgun,
a rifle for deer,
which is weird.
That is weird.
So that.
But that's why I got into archery.
Um.
Um,
and yeah,
I'm lucky because it's so close to the
city I can,
I can kind of go and hunt and then come
back to work in the morning.
Yeah.
The Kyle thing is interesting because
it's very counterintuitive.
The more coyotes you kill,
the more coyotes breed.
More kyle populations increase.
Coyotes are off.
There are a big problem,
at least in Canada and where I'm from,
they've,
you know,
like you were talking about the mountain
lions,
that's kind of our version.
They don't think there's any mountain
lions where I live,
but um,
the coyotes are problem,
their nab and people's dogs and cats
everywhere off,
off,
off the trail.
People were walking on their leash and
they're coming out and nail in their
little dogs out here.
I had one kill a chicken of mine two
weeks ago.
Crazy.
Yeah.
I've got a video of the dead fucking
chicken and my chicken coop.
And then the,
here's what's really dark.
I dug a hole and a bird.
The chicken,
we don't eat our chickens,
we just use the eggs or eggs and they're
like pets.
I mean,
like there's a video me from my
instagram walking in my yard holding my
daughter's bunny and the chickens.
They're like,
they're following me around it.
I wrote I'm the motherfucking chicken
because it's a crazy video because these
chickens just follow me.
I mean they literally,
they're like pets.
So when this chicken died,
I was bummed out.
It was a sweetheart of a chicken too.
And this was a chicken that we used to.
We would turn over rocks and she would
come and get the worms and so she would
follow you around.
I'm like,
come on sweetie.
Here we go.
And it's really like a pet.
Oh,
here it is.
Here's a video of me walking,
like,
look at them.
That's so cool.
They just follow me around,
man.
I know a lot of farmers and people,
a little hobby farms.
They use chickens as insect control.
Yeah.
And their vegetable garden.
Oh,
they're great for that.
They're great for the.
They will fuck up some mikes too,
man.
You ain't never seen nothing like it.
No,
you never said I did not know that.
This is how I found out about it.
Um,
well one,
one way I found out about it,
a mouse got in the chicken coop and they
fucked that thing up and I was like,
wow,
that's crazy.
But then another thing happened was my
daughters found a hawk.
My wife decided in all of you,
women are always trying to like spruce
things up.
She decided she was going to change some
of these fences to a glass fence and the
hawks didn't get the memo and they sat,
they swan dived into this,
this glass wall,
and when we first put up the fence there
was like three hawks that got fucked up
and one of them died and we found one of
them that was just kod,
ended up blood coming out of its nose,
like literally it was like a UFC fight.
It was down and fucked up.
So,
uh,
my daughter's,
took this in and they put it in a large
cardboard box and they had to figure out
how to feed it because it was,
I think it was on Saturday and the
wildlife rescue place was not open on
the weekend.
And so we had to bring it into a place
on Monday.
So over the weekend we went to this pet
store that we to and they sell something
called pinkies.
It's a very cute term for baby mice that
can't really see yet.
And they're separated from their mother
and they feed them to snakes.
So mostly reptiles that for him too.
But these hawks would fuck these pinkies
up and so to try to give this hawk some
food while it was there over the
weekend.
So it didn't starve that my daughter's
brought them the pinkies and there was
one pinky left,
uh,
that the hawke didn't eat when we
brought the hock to the wildlife rescue
place.
So they,
they fix up the Hawk and they told us
the Hawk was,
they,
they took care of its wing and
eventually they released it back in the
wild.
So it was a nice story.
But there's this one pinky leftover and
the thing was going to die.
It wasn't with its mother,
it was too small to drink milk.
And they were like,
we want to keep it,
we want to keep it as a pet.
I'm like,
that doesn't make any sense.
You're just feeding its brothers and
sisters to this fucking Hawk and now you
guys want to keep it.
So I said,
listen,
I think we should feed it to the
chickens.
And they're like,
no.
It was like,
well,
what do you guys,
what are you crazy?
You can't keep it.
It's going to die.
Do you understand that?
And they said,
okay,
okay.
I go,
well listen.
You don't have to watch.
I'll just go out and do it.
Do I put that fucking thing down and I
have never seen those chickens.
So voracious attack that mouse and then
they were all chasing the one chicken
that had the mouse trying to steal it
from him.
Watch this.
Here's the chicken with a mouse right
here.
Look,
they get a mouse and they have fucked
that mouse up man,
and they try to steal it from each
other.
I came out tonight,
tonight,
there's one where a cat is playing with
a mouse,
a cat.
You've seen them one with the cat and
the chicken.
Jamie.
That's the best one because the cat,
everybody thinks of cats is being
vicious.
Cats are pretty vicious.
Chickens are fucking dinosaurs,
man.
The way the chicken attacks the mouse
like here it is.
See,
look at that guy.
He's going to eat this shit out of that
mouse too.
He's got a.
she's got to keep her eyes open.
Mics or those other constant coming
steal her mouth seat.
Look at her.
They're experts in bobbing and weaving
and turning their heads,
but so the cat is stocking the mouse and
the chickens like,
bitch,
you don't even know what you're doing.
The chicken just runs in and snatches it
right in front of the cat.
The cat's like,
seriously?
Like my mouse.
They're way more ruthless.
I mean,
birds are ruthless creatures and
chickens in particular are just.
I think it's just a part of their
natural diet.
Like when I'm a mouse would get look at
this,
see the cat,
the cat's like,
wow,
check out this mouse.
I can't believe how lucky I am.
So he's like,
you know,
cats for a cat.
Half of it's a game,
right?
They don't play with it.
Yeah,
there's chick hanging back.
But as soon as the chicken finds it
Neema,
that mouse does not seem scared of that
chat.
He's,
he's not scared of it that that mouse
has talked.
So look at the chickens like fuck you.
Give me that thing.
That is crazy.
Crazy.
I did not know that about chickens.
Oh Dude.
They'll fuck up.
It's just the way they do it too fast
too.
And they think of it as purely as food.
They're not thinking like the cat,
it's sport
for the cat.
It's kind of fun.
Cats probably fully fed and it's a house
cat,
fat house cat.
He's just looking to kill.
So that's nature.
That's nature.
People don't understand that they want
to,
they want to remove themselves from it
and that's great,
but I don't want to understand it.
They didn't want to understand it.
They want something that aligns with
their ideology and their ideology is
love and compassion.
Except for people that eat meat and then
death,
death threats.
I mean that's really what it is.
It's,
it's an ideological battle.
And in that sense,
veganism becomes very much like a
religion because you like,
you support all the people that are on
your side and the people that are
opposed to you are like apostates.
They're like,
they're like the negative people that
are trying to bring you to the dark side
to hell.
It gets,
it gets really crazy and there's a lot
of evidence on their side in terms of
like factory farming and the horrors of
factory farming.
And even the really incredibly poor
modern American diet that they see a lot
of people when they go Vegan,
what they're doing,
one of the best things that they're
doing is they're eliminating all the
bullshit.
They're eliminating all the trans fats
and all the fucking but all the terrible
shit that a lot of people eat that isn't
Vegan.
But the negative thing is most of them
were eating diets that are far too
carbohydrate rich.
And if they're not getting their blood
check,
they don't even know how unhealthy they
are.
They convinced themselves they're doing
much better than it feeling much better.
But a lack of cholesterol can fuck with
your hormone functions.
A lot of vegans have low hormones
because of that.
We,
uh,
one of our regulars Antler,
I was talking to me about his
experience.
He used to have a organic vegetable farm
and he's a six foot seven big,
huge,
tall Dutch white guy.
And he goes to me,
he says,
you know,
uh,
I was Vegan for a long time and had this
organic vegetable farm.
And I thought that I was doing my body a
service.
He said,
I thought I was doing something great
for my body,
and he got really sick and he went to
the doctor and the doctor said,
listen man,
you have to take supplements to
supplement the things you're not getting
from from eating meat or you have to go
back to eating meat because just some
people's bodies do better than others.
And I said a lot of Asian cultures are
more susceptible to to vegetable diets,
but he's like,
in reality he's like,
you know,
you're a,
you're a northern European descent and
you need to eat this stuff to be healthy
and that's when he,
he went back to eating meat and it,
it doesn't matter.
You know what,
what you're trying to.
Like,
he,
he was living on an organic vegetable
farm.
Like what,
what more healthy vegetables could he be
eating?
So B,
12 is a big one and B,
12 essentially only comes from things
other than vegetables.
You can get some of it from algae you
can get.
I mean,
you definitely can get it from meat.
It's rich and me.
And the other thing is iron iron.
You know,
people say,
well,
there's iron and vegetables,
there is,
but it's not very bioavailable,
right?
A lot of the various vitamins and even
protein and vegetables,
not very
bioavailable in most
and is how your body absorbs those
nutrients as well.
Like it might.
It might be written that that,
that substance,
but your body can't really absorb it.
Well,
it's just everybody's body's different.
I mean it's just that as an absolute
fact that there are some people that can
eat certain diets and be very healthy
and then other people eat them and they
have a really hard time with them.
But the other thing is that most of
these people that are talking about how
healthy and how great they feel,
there's a lot of it is sort of a placebo
effect and they're not getting blood
work done at everyone.
Regardless of what your diet is.
You should get blood work done just to
find out if you have any potential
problems that are on the horizon because
there's a lot of times you'll feel okay
and then you get your blood work done
and the doctor will tell you,
hey man,
you're really low and vitamin B and d
and a and you know you need this and
that and you know this is this.
The health consequences of not having
this stuff in your diet and if you are
committed to a Vegan diet,
there's ways that you can supplement and
this is my advice to people.
If you want to supplement,
first of all,
a algae is a great one.
It tastes like shit but it's very good
for your body and you just add it to
smoothies,
you know,
just add it with coconut milk or a bunch
of other things.
You can do it.
I mean you definitely can eat a vegan
diet and be healthy,
but you got to be on the ball,
you know,
and the [inaudible] one is a big one.
It's a massive amounts.
I was reading some crazy article the
other day,
said something like 90 percent of all
vegans or B,
12 deficient.
I've heard this.
I'm not an expert,
but I've been terrible.
It's terrible.
There's a guy named Chris Kresser that
I've had on my podcast before who's a
brilliant guy who is a,
he's an expert in diet nutrition who
started out as a macrobiotic Vegan and
had massive health problems and then
switched to eating meat eventually and
then really became a connoisseur of
organ meat,
which is like probably the most nutrient
dense food in the world.
I love.
That's my favorite thing about hunting
as the organ meat.
Me Too,
man.
I love liver,
liver and the heart.
Um,
I,
I went hunting and I came back and I
brought the heart into the restaurant
for the guys because I wanted to share
with them like the experience of eating,
like fresh killed,
like the heart was still warm when I
brought it to work.
And the way I like to use either tar
tar,
like just mince it up raw or cooked like
a steak.
So I cut it,
you know,
horizontally in,
into like,
it looks like a tenderloin steak and we
all got like this,
like buzz,
like we shot a double espresso or
something.
It was just like,
whoa.
And it's like,
it's so nutrient rich,
uh,
the organ meat.
I had Alexander Gustafson,
the podcast yesterday is a UFC number
one lightweight content light,
heavyweight contender,
big viking motherfucker,
but he gets all of his meat from hunting
for his training camps and everything
like that.
He hunts red deer in Sweden's where he
lives.
And we were both talking about how when
you eat really nutrient dense wild game,
it gives you like a stimulated effect.
Like your body is like,
yeah,
more of this.
Give me more of this.
It's,
there's something in it.
I don't know what.
And it just tastes.
It tastes like it's supposed to taste.
You can't explain it.
The flavor is totally different.
Even when we were buying from these
really cool game farms,
it's different than the deer that I go
and shoot and shoot because you know,
that deer I just shot.
It could be like six,
seven years old versus at the farm,
it's maybe one or two.
Um,
but again,
it's eating such a diverse diet and
it's,
you know,
my belief is that that's how we're
supposed to be eating.
Well,
it's definitely how we were eating for
the longest time and it is entirely
possible that if humans,
like say if you've got an isolated group
of humans that stuck to a very,
very rigid vegan diet for many,
many,
many generations,
it's entirely possible that our genes
would adapt to that diet and lifestyle.
It's totally possible.
The reality of your current physical
form is it's most likely not designed
for that and this is just based on genes
and on genetics and epigenetics and all
the various things that they've.
Methods that they've devised to try to
study.
What makes you a person and where,
where your ancestors came from and how
did,
how did your ancestors developed?
Did they eat mostly fish?
Like there's people that live like in,
in the northwest,
like the extreme,
like in Alaska and a inuits and people
there,
their entire history,
they've evolved from eating fish and
wail and whale blubber and seal and seal
fat and there's real changes to who they
are as people.
Like,
first of all,
one of the big ones is that people that
live up there,
their hands don't get cold like ours do
their hands doing.
I've heard that when,
when,
uh,
the indigenous communities,
um,
there was some program where they were
trying to get them to stop hunting
whales are and stop killing seals.
And the government was supplementing
with them with uh,
with,
with beef and cattle.
And their argument was this is not what
we're supposed to eat.
This is not what we're designed to eat.
You know,
we need the fat in the whale blubber to
stay warm.
Yeah.
It's Kinda weird.
It's weird.
Like why would we be forcing these
people to eat something that was foreign
to them?
And it's not.
The fat content in beef is way different
than whale and seal.
It's like apples and oranges.
Well,
it's also,
you're looking at what we were talking
about before,
like white meat from Turkey domestic
Turkey versus the Turkey.
That's a wild Turkey when you see cows,
but you get these corn fed cows,
you have this pale meat.
That meat is Pale because it's not as
good for you.
It's more filled with fat,
which tastes good,
but it's just.
It's not as nutrient dense.
When you have a moose steak,
you've seen a moose steak before,
right?
It's fucking.
Yeah,
but it's almost like like purple dark,
dark.
Yeah.
It's fucking dark,
man.
That's,
that's way different.
It's way different thing.
That cow is just some.
It's like the fattest laziest person,
you know,
like if you thought about like take an
athlete like Lebron James Who's just
like this super athlete and compare like
the composition of his body to some
fucking Slob who just drinks soda all
day and is tired,
is on antidepressants and antibiotics
because his body's fucking deteriorating
rapidly.
He's got arthritis and all of his joints
because he's too fat.
That literally is a cow that's literally
one of these fucking farm raised
overstuffed corn fed cows and they grind
that fat fuck into a hamburger.
It's just not the same.
I'm not endorsing eating Lebron James,
but I'm saying there's a difference in
what the composition of their body is.
It's a different thing.
It's a very different thing.
Totally.
Yeah.
I mean I think wild things,
whether it's wild salmon or you know,
even wild vegetables I think would be
probably
better for you.
So that's a big part of what I do is one
of the reasons why I love nature so much
as foraging and I take my kids out to
the woods and we'd go pick mushrooms and
since there were like,
you know,
babies,
my son has been dragged in the woods
since he was one.
What kind of mushrooms?
Uh,
so my favorite one to harvest where I
live is morals.
Oh yeah.
They're really funky looking to kind of
look like a brain or something.
Something weird them online.
I've never seen him in the wild.
There is nothing that tastes quite like
them that you can,
you can buy like a meat.
They're very needy,
they're very media and there's a couple
different kinds.
There's like black ones and white or
yellowish ones.
Um,
and they're just like,
it's so fascinating to go out into the
wild and pick your own food and when you
come home and cook it like nothing else
tastes like that.
And like mushrooms from the store,
the totally different.
And it's just something really special
that you can go and experience in the
wild.
Yeah.
Morels are a real weird
one and I've been reading up on them.
One of the strange things is when
there's fire forest fires,
they pop up like the neck the next
season.
They're like cleansing their,
their cleansing the earth.
I don't,
I'm not a my call just so I don't know.
Uh,
you know,
I just enjoy finding them and eating
them.
But I do know there's a cleansing
property to decaying a decaying matter.
So when trees fall down,
like the best place to find Morales is
a.
I look for trees with no bark on them.
So they're,
they're really super old,
it's called a dead elm tree and they
like the rotting roots of these dead elm
trees and you know,
you're,
you're in the bush and are in the field
and you kind of see this one tree that
has no bark on it and it's about to fall
over.
There'll be like 20 morels at the base
and they're,
they're kind of,
they're feeding off the root system
that's underground.
Yeah.
I'm absolutely fascinated by mushrooms.
I had a Paul stamets on the podcast,
so I saw that one.
How great is that?
Super Cool.
It was mushroom hat.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
I got to,
gave me too much.
Am I going to do it too in case one
breaks an extra mushroom hat
was a really cool documentary.
Um,
uh,
it's called know your mushrooms.
I think it's by Ron,
by Ron man.
And he,
he,
he travels along with these mushroom
hunters a up,
I think a lot of it's in Oregon and up
the coast of California down into
Mexico,
but they're,
they're professional foragers that then
go and sell these mushrooms.
Uh,
but they track these forgers and it's
such a cool movie.
That's interesting.
Um,
well I was going to say is you better
know mushrooms because they'll fucking
kill you if you don't have that.
That's the thing,
man.
It's like,
you know what,
my first experiencing foraging for
mushrooms,
I was like an apprentice chef at this
restaurant and the chef comes in and was
like,
hey,
check these out.
And I was like,
Whoa,
like what the hell are these?
And he's like,
oh,
their,
like,
I found them mountain biking and there's
this stigma,
you know,
like as,
as a kid,
like your parents were like,
don't,
don't eat those,
don't touch those.
They're poisonous,
they'll kill you.
And it's like,
okay,
well then you just,
you just have this idea.
Well,
mushrooms come from the grocery store
will take.
No,
they grow,
they come in the wild and you know,
that's my thing with me is I teach my
kids like meat doesn't come from the
grocery store.
It's not,
it's not a styrofoam package.
That's not where it comes from.
It's an animal.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and yeah,
and it's just like,
you know,
mushrooms that grow in the wild and
they're just,
they're crazy.
They like Michael Micro cycle rises.
Yeah.
Michael Riser,
relationship with the animals or with
the trees rather.
Um,
do you know the story of the laminated
Ms Dot area?
I know what they are.
Uh,
I don't know the story.
The to miscarry is the most fascinating
one to me because that's the one that
looks like it looks like Santa Claus or
the marks card with washroom.
Yeah.
That is the subject of a book by a guy
named John Marco Allegro who was one of
the head scholars for deciphering the
Dead Sea Scrolls.
He deciphered the Dead Sea Scrolls for
14 years.
He was an ordained minister,
but he was also in his study of theology
became agnostic and these sort of when
you started realizing that there was all
these different religions that had
similar stories and he was found all
these different connections and he was
trying,
trying to figure out what the origins of
all these stories where.
Well,
after studying the Dead Sea Scrolls for,
I think it was 14 years before he wrote
this book,
he decided that all of Christianity was
a massive misunderstanding,
and what it was originally about was
these stories,
these collection of stories that were
about fertility rituals and psychedelic
mushroom use,
and he traced the word Jesus back to an
ancient Sumerian word that was a
mushroom covered in God's semen and that
when God would come on the earth,
that's what rain was.
Rain was God coming on the earth and
that these mushrooms would rise up out
of the ground.
They would eat them and trip they're
fucking balls off.
That's a crazy story.
So maybe you got to think people that
were foraging for food,
especially back when there was no
agriculture,
right?
I mean it was,
it was touch and go.
You could easily starve to death.
You mean you're a bad winter.
You know,
a drought.
People would starve to death.
It was very,
very common.
So they would take foraging extremely
serious,
and they knew what they could eat and
they knew what they couldn't eat.
While they knew that there was a
relationship between coniferous trees
and coniferous trees would grow these
weird looking shiny red and white
mushrooms under him.
That's what coniferous trees,
pine trees.
That's what we use for Christmas trees.
Those red and white packages,
they.
They are like the shiny packages
underneath the Christmas tree.
They are the color of Santa Claus.
There are common inside barrier.
There are eaten constantly by Caribou.
Caribou are reindeer.
Reindeer are addicted to these to the
point where when people are having
psychedelic mushroom rituals and they go
outside to take a leak,
the Karabal will knock them over to get
to the Amany to miscarry a piss in the
sand because they smell the Amanita
Mascara in the pis and one of the ways
these guys trip their balls off as they
eat the mushroom and then they drink
their own urine,
has a second process of this.
Here's where it gets even crazier in the
times in Siberia where it become
extremely snowy.
When this shaman would visit,
the way they would get into the house is
through the fucking chimney because the
door would be snowed in so they would
climb in through the chimney.
I mean,
there's so many parallels to Santa Claus
and to Christianity to this one mushroom
that they think was a massive part of
shamanistic rituals.
There it is right there.
This is this Rudolph,
the red nose reindeer.
Yeah.
Oh,
that is such a cool story.
Oh Dude.
It's fucking crazy.
So he wrote this book called the Sacred
Mushroom in the cross that was bought
out by the Catholic Church.
This I have to verify,
but I do know that they stopped
production of it.
I don't know if it was bought out by the
Catholic Church.
That's always been what's been told to
me,
but I do know that they stopped
production of it forever.
Um,
he came out with another book called the
Dead Sea Scrolls in the Christian myth,
which is still available.
Then more recently,
like really recently,
within the last decade,
uh,
a guy named Yon Irvin republished the
John Marco Allegro books with permission
from his family.
I think it might've actually been one of
those things where when a book is over
25 years old,
it becomes public domain or something
like that too,
but this,
this book and this story behind it is
incredibly fascinating and what he's
basically saying is that it makes sense
if you were living thousands of years
ago when you stumbled upon these
psychedelic mushrooms and you took them,
you would experience God.
You literally would think that that
psychedelic state was you communicating
with God.
They would want to hide those from the
Romans.
So they hid them in parables and stories
and he explains what the original
meaning of all these parables and
stories are.
Because of course you're going from
ancient Hebrew,
which is extremely complicated language
that also involves numbers.
The letters are also numbers and then
that's translated to Latin and Greek and
then eventually to English.
So a lot is lost in that translation.
So it really takes a linguist and a
biblical scholar to kind of understand
whether
or not what this guy is saying is
correct.
I'm obviously not one of those,
so I'm just talking shit,
but it's uh,
there's so many parallels.
It's almost like,
how could it be just coincidental that
Santa Claus is red and white at Santa
Claus legs reindeers,
that the Christmas tree is something
that we used in the presence or under
the Christmas tree that Santa Claus
lives the fucking North Pole,
which is Siberia,
which is where Caribou live in,
which is where these mushrooms are very
common.
I mean,
there's so many parallels.
It's really kind of fucking crazy.
That's cool.
Yeah.
It's a great book.
Anybody I really highly recommend it
because it's one of those books.
We just got to read a few chapters and
you got to go.
Okay.
I think I may have to go back over that
again.
We'll go over and again.
So it's,
it's so freaky.
Very cool.
But I've stumbled upon those in the
wild.
Those never found those.
There's like,
you have to cook them first.
You can eat them raw.
You have to boil them.
We will make you sick apparently if you
don't do it right.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
I,
I forge more for Merelda my favorite.
Uh,
Shannon Charles,
obviously like awesome culinary
mushrooms.
Uh,
what's that yellow one that grows on
trees?
It's like a thick,
a chicken of the woods.
Yes.
That one's real and it tastes like
chicken.
It is unbelievable.
That one's amazing.
It's really funky.
We found I was walking with the kids and
a park downtown Toronto and I look over
and there's this massive,
it's on my instagram,
a massive yellow kinda looks like goo
growing on this tree and it was a
premature chicken of the woods and it
just looked like this blob and then if I
were to leave it,
it would start to kind of a shelf out
into like shelf kind of mushrooms.
And so I left it for like a week and
went back and harvested and it's like,
it's like tender,
juicy chicken flavor.
It is bizarre.
Oh that's Kinda cool.
So you were just hoping nobody else saw
and thing and it wasn't like a really
public park and I was like,
Oh man,
like I better get this before someone
else finds it.
Wow.
How many people would know in a public
park in Toronto?
Uh,
there's a few.
There's,
there's Wsu.
I've,
I've kind of walked up to ladies like
picking herbs and stuff and I was like,
Hey,
like what do you do?
And then they kind of looked at me and
kind of went away.
They didn't want to share their
knowledge with me.
Here it is,
there it is.
So that's the bizarre man zoo.
Zookeeper.
And I was like,
I was so pumped.
I was so excited.
Face you make you look like Krista Leah
there.
But that's hilarious.
Oh that's so cool.
It's like a little tiny one below it on
trees.
I don't know.
I think.
Well that one you can see the bark is
deteriorating.
So again,
it's,
it's a,
it's feeding off the decaying a treat.
So look how bad asset.
So if that,
if you actually go.
And I found ones like that too.
If you go in and harvest those,
they're really woody by that time and
they're,
they're kind of a little too tough.
Oh really?
Um,
so yeah,
you wanna you wanna get them when
they're younger like that.
So is there a color change?
Um,
I,
I get,
I guess when,
when they're older they get a bit more
orange from that kind of yellow
premature stacy,
that one where there's like yellow,
yellow.
Those are like perfect.
Yeah,
right there.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That looks like almost like cauliflower.
Totally.
Yeah.
It's really,
really neat.
Wow.
It's fascinating.
You know,
the,
the mushroom world is,
is a super cool.
Do you know they breathe air.
I did not know that.
They breathe air,
they breathe out carbon dioxide,
you're closer to animals and they are
the vegetables.
That's really cool.
And they're weird.
Fungus is a weird thing.
Then one,
a lot of it's like I'm misunderstood.
Well,
I,
I guess I was,
I was watching the podcast with them,
with the mushroom guy.
Yeah.
Shout out to Paul Depaul.
Um,
but like a lot of it is,
is still being learned today of,
of,
of the impact on,
on the earth.
And when what they do.
Did you hear a story about how would he
take 10 grams of psilocybin mushrooms
and climbed a tree was in a lightning
storm and like connected to the fucking
universe,
first time ever doing it.
Right.
And he just don't ever do it.
Yeah,
he did that.
I think he was in high school,
right?
Or some.
Somewhere around that.
Very young.
Yeah.
Crazy.
He's awesome.
Such a trip though,
and I was reading the filicides is
linked to your and curing depression and
things like that,
which,
which I don't know a lot about,
but it's fascinating the effects they
have on,
on,
uh,
on people.
John Hopkins is doing some studies on
them.
The most fascinating of all the mushroom
theories is by the late great terence
Mckenna and his brother Dennis Mckenna,
who's still alive and a scientist
explained it on my first podcast with
him.
So if anybody's interested,
find that in downloaded.
It's Dennis is a brilliant guy and this
theory is called the stoned ape theory.
And this coincides what we were talking
about about hunting and con con,
consumption of meat.
I'm leading to us becoming humans.
There's a doubling of the human brain
size over a period of 2 million years.
It's like apparently one of the biggest
mysteries in the fossil record.
They do not understand why something so
important like the thing that actually
created the theory of evolution,
explained evolution like this very
Oregon doubled over a period of 2
million years and you don't know why.
Terrence believes that the reason
coincided with climate change and that
as the climate changed,
these rain forest receded into
grasslands and these lower hominids like
our ancestors came down from the trees
and started experimenting with new food
sources and one of the things they
experimented with with psychedelic
mushrooms and that through Psilocybin,
which they found by flipping over cow
patties.
A couple things happened.
One,
it increased visual acuity mushrooms,
especially in low doses,
increased visual acuity which would make
them better hunters.
They could see better,
made them more intuitive,
made them more creative.
And also the way Dennis explains the
effect of Psilocybin on the brain.
He was saying that it could have
possibly led to the development of
language and that all of this could have
come out of the consumption of
psychedelic mushrooms.
It's fucking intense,
man.
Terrence called it stoned ape theory.
That's what he,
that's how he thinks we became human.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it sounds stupid.
It sounds stupid until you do mushrooms.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Then you go,
oh,
okay.
Okay.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe.
I is this illegal.
Then you start going,
what?
Everybody should do this.
Oh my God.
Now.
When you first started cooking,
um,
did when,
how old were you when you became a chef?
Um,
well,
it's kind of a fluke.
Funny Story.
Um,
I was a 13 year old kid and I wanted a
part time job,
you know,
like a newspaper route or something like
that.
And I went to,
I lived in a little town on this horse
farm in the country and I rode my bike
down to this gas station and I applied
to pump gas and this guy had a diner on
the corner and was like,
hey man,
like I don't need anyone to pump gas but
can you cook?
And I grew up cooking at home with my
mom because she would work late and she
would call me on her way home and tell
me how to start dinner,
be like,
turn on the oven,
get the chicken out of the fridge,
get the shake and bake and,
you know,
she would walk me through it and I'd
start dinner and she'd get home and
finish it.
So I totally,
yeah,
I can cook or whatever.
And he had had me in there,
you know,
like dropping the fry baskets and
flipping eggs and you know,
doing the brunch shift on the weekend
and it just stuck.
It's one of those things that uh,
you just kind of grow up doing.
I,
you know,
I wanted money to buy skateboards and
pot and stupid shit.
And um,
yeah,
just,
it just kind of stuck.
And then,
uh,
all through high school I had a job
cooking and I really started to struggle
with it because,
uh,
you know,
I was taking all these world issues
courses and learning about the
environment and watching these
documentaries about food and I didn't
know,
you know,
how being a chef could help change the
world and how am I going to make a
difference as a chef.
Um,
and then,
uh,
and then I had,
I had my daughter when I was 19 and I
had all this experience cooking and I
thought,
well,
you know,
I'm just gonna go to chef school and uh,
and make a go of this.
Like I've got all this experience.
I'm already this far ahead.
And uh,
it was,
it was having kids at such a young age
that really made me focus and was like,
okay,
like I have a job to do.
And uh,
I fell in love with food.
Uh,
I,
you know,
it was a 17 year old kid with a
vegetable garden,
like who does that,
you know,
and uh,
and then I got into hunting and foraging
and learning about food and I just,
I totally just fell in love with it.
And so how did antler come about?
He brought a bunch.
A bunch of these.
Yeah.
So this photo,
uh,
I actually took this photo.
It's blown up in the restaurant.
All the green on the ground is a wild
leeks.
So in the spring.
And I actually took this Turkey hunting,
um,
and I looked over and was like,
well,
cool,
that's amazing.
And just took the photo postcard.
This is actually a sketch.
My friend did have a,
have a deer skull that I shot.
Um,
so anyway,
lyric came about because,
um,
I worked for a celebrity chef.
Uh,
he gave me his cookbook and I was
hunting and foraging,
doing all the stuff and I thought,
well,
you know,
one of the ways I can make an impact in
the world that I can teach people about
what I'm doing.
And,
uh,
I went and got a,
I got a camera and I would take it with
me and shoot photos like this,
and I wanted to teach people about
hunting and foraging because what I was
doing is not new.
It's really,
really old.
But,
uh,
you know,
people seem to have forgotten about it,
at least people in the cities anyway,
people don't really know much about it.
So I thought,
you know,
I'm going to help educate,
a modern civilization about hunting and
foraging and this'll be like my make a
difference in the world.
And,
uh,
I ended up hanging out with a really
good friend of mine,
um,
one of my best friends today.
And he's a family friend,
a documentary film maker by the name of
Jody Shapiro.
Um,
and,
you know,
we had this deal and you said,
I'll,
I'll help you with the photos if you
teach me how to cook.
And he was,
he was taking some culinary courses at
the local college just as a hobby.
And,
uh,
you know,
we started hanging out and shooting this
cookbook.
And um,
we started to kind of get some press
about it,
um,
you know,
eater magazine did this article on us
and we started doing these game dinners
out of his house and he had this really
nice condo and so I put on this game
dinner,
I sold tickets and I knew there were
laws about serving game and restaurant.
So in Canada,
and I appreciate the,
u.
s is pretty similar.
You can't serve wild game in a
restaurant.
So there's public health.
Excuse me,
I'm amit has to be inspected through a
slaughterhouse.
Europe is different.
You can kind of do whatever in Europe.
But so I thought okay cool,
we'll have this game dinner out of his
house and we're in the clear.
But with the,
with the Ministry of natural resources,
you can't sell game meat.
So for any kind of profit,
but we weren't profiting off it.
We just going to have some fun.
Um,
and we do this game dinner,
a local paper,
a national paper actually wanting to buy
a ticket.
They came,
we thought they're going to write this
little blurb about it.
They did a two page spread in the
national newspaper about this game
dinner.
So we started to get all this press
about it.
And um,
we just said,
hey,
let's,
let's open a restaurant.
Let's,
let's have a home where we can,
we can,
you know,
work on this book,
possibly shoot some documentary and
really just have fun and explore a
Canadian cuisine.
It's something that I'm really
passionate about.
Something that really hasn't really been
defined.
There's a bunch of people trying to
define it.
Um,
you know,
and,
uh,
and it was just sort of our home.
Now when you say Canadian cuisine or
these traditional recipes,
or are they improvise?
Well,
I,
you know,
a lot of it is improvised.
It's a lot of,
it's my take on it.
Um,
you know,
I,
I definitely want to do some more kind
of studying about native and indigenous
cooking.
Um,
you know,
traveling across the country,
something that I want to do and learning
from the indigenous communities.
Um,
but sort of my take on it is,
you know,
if there,
if there wasn't these farmed animals,
what would be,
what would we eat?
And for me,
it's,
it's morals,
it's maple syrup,
it's the wild leeks in this photo,
it's deer and Turkey and rabbit and
these things we all serve at antler
because that's what's growing around us
in Canada.
It's wild fish.
And thanks again for the map.
I'm going to have to break my diet to
enjoy some of this liquid ious looking
richest looking.
Ever seen that,
that looks amazing.
So I was telling you earlier that takes
18 liters of sap boiled down to make one
liter of syrup.
And the cool part is you can drink the
sap.
It's a natural,
uh,
it's full of a lot of natural
electrolytes and minerals.
So it's Kinda like a coconut water,
a type of beverage.
What's crazy to me is how someone
figured out to do that and they've been
doing it for hundreds of years,
right?
Yeah.
Super Cool.
And it happens only you can only make it
in the spring when it's freezing at
night and it was during the day.
And what happens is the tree roots are
sucking up as much water as it can to
feed the buds that it's trying to,
uh,
to make,
to make leaves again.
How the fuck did anybody figure that
out?
No idea.
Take the sap from the trees like that.
So simple.
It's,
it's really,
really cool to when,
when you,
when you go,
you know,
you drill a hole in the tree,
you put in this little tap and hang a
bucket and it just drips out and.
Wow.
And how long does it take to drip when
it's,
when it's like kind of perfect
conditions.
I put up these 16 liter buckets and
within like three or four days they're
full.
Oh Wow.
So it's cool.
It's fun.
And it gets me out in the woods.
I call it my spring training because I'm
lugging around all these buckets,
you know.
Oh,
okay.
That's great.
So that's awesome.
That winter fat off.
So when you were talking about
indigenous people,
how they would cook their food,
what have you learned?
Any of those dishes yet?
Um,
I have,
um,
like I said,
I'm not an expert,
but it's something I'm,
we're,
we're going to be kind of studying,
moving forward are,
you know,
the growth of Antler,
where do we go from here?
Um,
and you know,
as I mentioned,
my,
my business partner is a documentary
guy,
so we,
we,
we want to travel and travel across the
country and learn really what that is.
Um,
there's so many different indigenous
communities in Canada.
Canada is on three coasts,
uh,
you know,
much like the states with Alaska,
you don't really think of the Arctic up
there,
but uh,
you know,
there's three ocean that ocean,
so it's not an ocean to walk across it.
It's frozen.
But uh,
yeah,
it's uh,
it's something that I definitely want to
learn more about.
Um,
like how would they cook Moose,
you know?
Um,
a lot of it would be open fire in a lot
of it's raw seal meat and whale blubber,
you know,
they don't,
like in the Arctic,
they don't have a lot of wood to burn,
you know,
and they would have like a oil lamps
from the oil,
from the blubber.
But uh,
you know,
a lot of the cooking is raw.
Yeah.
Steven Rinella went to new Nevada.
Is that a new event?
Yeah,
yeah,
something like that.
I think it's been,
I think there's,
yeah,
the North Northwest Territories and
there's new boot and they were eating a
lot of fish,
frozen fish that was dipped in seal oil,
dip the fish and seal oil,
eat it.
They have a tremendous amount of oil and
fat in their diet,
you know,
which kind of makes sense.
Got It.
Yeah.
I mean they're,
they're up there in the coldest of cold
climates.
One of the things we do this kind of
cool is uh,
uh,
I know the native in the indigenous
cultures
would,
would make cedar tea and it's full of
vitamin C and minerals and nutrients.
But we do a cedar a sorbet.
So we boil cedar leaves and then I just
add sugar and make it into like an ice.
So it's a frozen kind of survey,
which is really cool.
And it's,
it's like,
uh,
when you eat it,
it's like the forest and your mouth,
it's really,
really easy.
And then you get the cedar from.
We just go into the woods and cut it
down and we'll bring that into the
restaurant.
There's all kinds of cool stuff that we
do that we,
you know,
because I go up,
I try and be in nature a couple times a
week,
um,
and I'll go and forage for all this
stuff and bring it into antler.
Uh,
another way we use the cedar isn't a
cocktail.
We do a cedar gin sour,
so we infuse,
infuse the gin with a,
with cedar leaves for like a week.
And then we shake that with some simple
syrup and make me hungry.
So when you,
um,
it's interesting that when you go to the
woods to forage for plant life,
it's totally legal.
Yeah.
You could sell it.
But if you forge for animal life,
you can't do that.
I think that is because of market
hunting that really decimated most of
the population of North American game
animals in the 18 hundreds and early
into the 19 hundreds.
Like mo.
Most people associate that with the
death of the buffalo,
the,
uh,
it makes sense.
And I think,
I think if there,
there are ways to do it where it could
be controlled.
I don't think I could hunt enough Meat
for the,
for the restaurant,
but five seats,
45 seats.
But you know what I,
I do think I do think that,
you know,
I think it's people's right to be able
to eat wild meat.
I think that as a human being,
you have the right to try that.
And if you're not a hunter,
if you don't know how to go do it,
you have the right to at least try it.
Um,
and I do know in newfoundland they're
allowed to serve wild game and the
hunter has to go and get a permit to
sell and then he has to bring it to a
butcher that has a permit to process it
and expect it and then not butcher can
then sell to a restaurant.
Oh,
well that makes sense.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's controlled and like I don't want to
decimate the population.
I don't want to hurt a anything.
Is that the way to say it though?
New found land,
newfoundland.
Yeah,
I think it's definitely not.
Call it new found land.
It's like calling chicago chicago.
Get pissed at you.
Like fake canadian.
I have an aunt from there.
Yeah.
I don't want market hunting of wild
game.
It's Because I love wild animals and
hundred percent again.
What do you,
how do you love an animal?
Yeah,
well I just think it's very complex.
That's what I think.
I think just staying alive,
being a human is very complex and I
think we have very simplistic ways of
looking at it.
I also think that it's entirely possible
that plants are communicating with each
other and they have a level of
intelligence that we don't totally
understand and that's supported by data
that supported by more and more research
every day.
They're finding out that plants have
some interconnected network of
communication with each other and that
they recognize when they're being and
they changed their flavor profile to
make themselves tastes terrible to
animals that are eating them.
There's some communication between them
and there are some sort of a primitive
life form that many are.
You are far more complex than things
that vegans won't eat like mollusks
mollusks,
although we think of them as animals,
they're the simplest,
dumbest fucking thing on earth vice.
Just an article that a questioning
whether mollusks we're vegan.
I thought it was funny.
They shouldn't be.
I think for health purposes,
people that are vegans like,
hey man,
they're.
They're sustainable.
I mean you could farm them.
You could have anything property to have
something that they were using muscles
to clean up.
Ocean beaches,
filter the water and a fast and
mushrooms to apparently are very
cleansing there.
They're trying to find ways to use
mushrooms to clean kind of oil spills
and yes,
screwed up environmental things.
People should eat mandalas,
they really should and they should also
eat eggs,
folks.
Just from An ethical animals,
and I'm just saying this just as a
person who values health in a person
who's.
I mean I,
I put my body through a lot.
My body has to.
It has to perform and it has my whole
life.
So I'm very,
very concerned with nutrition and I'm
very aware of the impact attrition has
on physical performance and I think eggs
are gigantic.
They're so goddamn good for your health
and this idea that somehow know that
you're doing something cruel.
My chickens are my friends.
You see it from that video that's proven
in the pudding,
that scared of me at all.
That runnIng around with their running
around with me and I eat their eggs and
those eggs are good for.
And I know everybody can't do that,
but you can get these toilets.
It's eggs and you vote with your dollars
that you're spending.
You know,
if you go to the store and you buy
organic eggs and you buy the healthier
version,
yes,
you're paying an extra buck or two bucks
or whatever it is,
but crack open an egg from like the mass
produced place and you crack open an egg
from the organic place.
One is like the organic ones are like
bright orange and like super dark and
even the yolk is like really thick and
then the other one it's like pale and
runny yellow and you crack them and the
yolks break sometimes and they're just
like,
it's garbage and who knows what's in
them and what conditions those chickens
are living in.
A lot of times terrible conditions.
I think whoever started off,
I mean I guess it's just economics,
right?
And then you give people the option to
make the most amount of money and not
have to account for ethics or cruelty
standards or whatever.
You know,
whatever issues were in place that
allowed factory farms to materialize.
That's one of the worst,
worst pieces of evidence about the
cruelty of human beings.
It's one of the worst.
It's horrific.
I mean,
and it's,
it's something that I think we should
really collectively do something about
and absolutely,
it's one of the things that really ramps
up the,
the anger on the side of the animal
rights activists and the side of the
vegans.
I get it,
but to go after someone like you is in
my opinion,
so incredibly misguided and it's why I
asked you to come on because I thought
it was so frustrating and watching you
carved that venice and up in front of
those people.
What were they screaming at you?
Murderer murder.
That's not true.
It's like saying,
you know,
it's just like saying you're a thief
because you cut grass.
It's no,
it's not.
It's not murder.
It's,
it's kIlling animals.
We even,
even the video,
someone's walking by and they're like,
they're saying they're murderers and
she's like,
they're murdering people and like,
no,
they're murdering animals.
The kind of laugh.
A lot of those people are sad,
like a lot of like what you're dealing
with with these animal rights activists
that they're,
they're so engrossed in this struggle
and it's the part of their,
their daily existence and they're,
they're angry and sad.
There's one crazy video where this lady
goes into this restaurant and she starts
yelling in front of everybody about her
friend and just be this beautiful
creature that just wants to live and
it's a chicken.
She's talking about chicken and like my
friend,
that chicken was killed and it's like,
what?
Whoa.
And everybody in the restaurant,
it's like,
what the fuck?
I've seen these videos and they're like,
they'll storm a restaurant.
There'll be like 50 people that go and
occupy a steakhouse.
Here's this crazy lady.
Oh god,
here we go,
girl.
She was very abused for her entire life.
She was terrified.
she has a very determined look in her
eyes wherever she goes,
and she was hurt and abused her entire
life because of this establishment and
because of establishments like it,
she was locked away.
She with hidden.
She got nobody there for her.
She was crying.
She was scared every single moment
we have a maitre d because they're
useful,
had run out.
Someone's going to hear and I can see
you laughing,
smiling.
At least at least we're not busy.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's such a restaurant way of taking
you with me right now.
She wouldn't be gone just like,
where's the chicken part?
All of those other girls.
But where is this crazy town?
Disrupt.
It's unfair to those mice.
Oh,
eating somebody else's eggs.
Remember her name,
her name,
a beautiful little girl.
She's a mouse.
Murder.
violence.
They sing it together.
They all get together with science.
Think of this.
Okay.
Cut it short.
See the way your little bird snow fucks
up a warm you crazy bitch.
Fucks up.
Mice,
throat,
mouse in the cage.
No snow.
Only grain.
That guy's funny.
It's kind of amazing.
So yeah,
there's,
there's protesting and it's like it's,
it's our fundamental right to protest
and have freedom of speech and have
these things,
but that's not protesting.
That's disrupting a business.
yeah,
there's not,
it's not the place for it.
That's harassment.
Look,
if the best place for something like
that is really what we just saw a video.
Make a video about your thoughts.
Yeah.
You know if you mean if they honestly
think that we're doing is wrong.
Like this is what something like youtuBe
is for.
Make a video where you state your case.
I'll come and talk to me and didn't even
come and talk to me.
we'll just start at my restaurant with
science,
but at least wIth the video you'll leave
the comments open and then people
debate.
They decide whether or not they agree or
disagree.
Are you fucking crazy asshole?
Let that snow loose.
Watch what she does.
Watch what she does to every fucking
buck she finds she's a murderer.
She's not.
She's not a vegetarian.
You fucking chickens out a vegetarian.
It's just not.
You know,
people lIke vegetarian fed.
Well then you got a sick chicken because
that's not what they're supposed to eat.
It seemed like cats.
Cats need meat.
You can't feed a cat.
A vegan dIet like you can see.
One of my bits,
I have a bit about it.
do you really fucking hilarious because
it's something that I found online when
someone's angry at me,
when someone was angry at me,
I went to her page and it's one of the
things said hashtag vegan cat.
I went,
oh jesus.
I went down.
That was illegal in animal rights.
People will come and should tinker.
Cat.
We'll talk about that later.
I don't want to do my bit.
I'm doing it on a comedy special zone,
but the,
the,
the problem with this is that as we said
before,
it becomes like a contest.
It becomes like a,
like a battle ground.
yeah.
That's my concern is like,
how does this end?
How do we bridge the gap?
How do we get people like,
how do they stop fucking with you?
I have no idea that.
well,
theIr,
their thing is they want us to put a
sign in our window that's explained
that,
that you know,
we're mistreating animals and animal
lives or their right and they say,
you know,
this extortion,
if we put this sign in our window,
they're going to go away.
Well,
we're not doing anything wrong.
You know,
nothing we're doing is illegal.
We're not infringing on anyone's rights.
Have you talked to them at all if you
gone outside?
So,
no,
we had one of our managers go outside
and there,
they just screamed at her.
They were,
this isn't the time.
I think just murderer.
What about snow girl?
So,
you know,
we,
we did send an email trying to,
we invited them to go foraging with us.
Uh,
and we talked about our different
ideologies,
ideologies and how,
you know,
they're,
they're really far
apart,
but maybe we can come to some kind of
understanding and,
and uh,
you know,
at the,
at the time they didn't respond,
they didn't respond for awhile and now I
don't,
I don't think I'm a,
you know,
I don't,
I don't think that anything good would
come with that meeting at this point.
So,
so what do you do?
How's business?
By the way?
Business has always been good for us.
We were very lucky.
I'm like,
you have a great restaurant.
I mean,
I'm sure that's part of it.
Thank you.
but we,
we've,
we've had some international
recognition.
Um,
we've,
I've done a lot of traveling last year,
I've been to five continents in the last
year or two of them cooking.
Uh,
I went to abu dhabi with a,
there's a company called img and if you
know them,
they own the ufc,
now they run,
they have a culinary department and they
run these festivals called taste.
Um,
and our first year opening we were part
of this taste festival and uh,
I didn't even know there was a
competition going on.
These people came by and they were lIke,
oh,
we're judging this competition and we
want to try your food.
And I was like,
well,
I think these people are trying to get
some free food out of me.
They were like,
yeah,
you can win a trip to abu dhabi.
And I was like,
oh,
okay,
whatever.
And we actually won and they sent me to
abu dhabi to,
uh,
to compete against 11 other chefs from
around the world.
Uh,
and it was amazing.
It was incredible.
Um,
and then from there,
uh,
I think six slash six or eight months
later,
there was a festival in Australia.
So they brought me to Australia to,
uh,
to cook in western Australia,
this a event called the gourmet escape,
a really,
really cool event and it was down the
road from a deer farm and we were
putting out a lunch and dinner for 200
people.
So we actually roasted to hold dear sato
style over open fire,
uh,
and you do that.
Uh,
rAn the woods.
it was incredible photos on my instagram
or the antler kitchen borrowed up to or
at antler kitchen bar on instagram.
There's photos of this,
uh,
this uh,
sato.
It was super,
super,
super cool.
So sato sato is a,
I think it's the argentinian cooking
style and it's,
it's a whole,
uh,
animal that's a kind of split down the
middle and kind of like cross across.
Yeah,
there is.
It's really cool.
So pig is probably the best one to do it
with because of the fat content,
a deer and lamb and stuff like that.
You kind of have to base it to keep it
moist.
How do you regulate temperature when it
comes to something like that?
It's just stacking up the wood and kind
of how far leaning on it and some of
that to do it.
It just practice,
just playing around.
Um,
fun.
It just lay low and slow.
Was kind of ready to go for many times.
Yeah.
So we do at the restaurant,
I do it in my backyard a lot.
I actually did for my wedding,
we did two pigs from my wedding.
I'm like poking the fire and my suit.
That's so graphic.
It's great.
Yeah.
That got a lot of hate.
There's hate on that.
Um,
but it's food,
you know,
and people want to disconnect themselves
from where it's coming from.
Um,
but he went back to your question,
you know,
business has always been good in
businesses,
good days and bad days.
You know,
right now there's a lot of attention on
antler,
lot of media attention on antler.
So,
uh,
we're,
you know,
we're a little bit busier than normal
right now.
Get ready,
just
get crazy.
It's gonna be nuts down there and
there's going to be a bunch of people on
your side to hopefully nothing bad
happens.
Like,
people don't get into anything physical
or you can start shouting at each other,
but that
shouting stuff was happening.
But uh,
but yeah,
hopefully this will kind of smooth out
and people can learn to get it to get
along and lifting
together.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't seem like that's what
they want though.
It seems like what they want is for you
to bend their demands.
I mean that's what a lot of this is when
it comes to change,
you know,
when it comes to people wanting change,
they want you to change and they want
their right and they want you to admit
you're wrong.
And this is,
this is a real problem.
The real problem with something that's
complex.
Yeah.
And the funny thing was like we've had
vegan and vegetarian items on our menu
since 2015 when we opened.
And so I think it was like the second or
third week they came,
we thought okay,
we're going to,
we're going to feature one of our vegan
dishes on the sign and hopefully that
makes them happy.
And so we feature one of our vegan
dishes on the sign.
And then we saw from their online post
that they thought that we made the posts
where we made them change a meat dish to
a vegan dish.
We have to keep pUshing them.
And it was so frustrating.
Like,
no,
you guys don't know who we are.
Well that's exactly what I'm talking
about.
It,
it becomes a contest or a battle ground
and Ideological battle ground.
Yeah.
This,
this thought that they're making you
change,
they want you to change.
You know?
I mean I've seeN.
I saw a video once where people were mad
at me too and they were like,
he's listening so he's open to change.
And I was like,
no,
like I'm listening because I want to
hear your perspective like you're not
right.
Like,
and I'm not right.
It's like we have our own perspectives
and I'm not going to change if I change.
It's because of the evidence and because
of thinking and careful consideration
and I've done that.
I've done a lot of thinking.
I've done a lot of kale for careful
consideration.
And that's what led me to becoming a
hunter in the first place.
yeah.
What,
how did you start hunting?
Stephen?
Noah took her.
I had been thinking about it for a long
time and the main reason I've been
thinking about it was because of those
pet videos,
those fucking horrific factory farming
videos.
I was like,
I don't want to eat that.
I don't want.
I want him to be a part of this.
I want to figure out how to not.
So I started buying grass fed meat and I
tried to figure out a way to get around
it and I really started getting very,
very interested in hunting,
but I didn't know how to start.
I didn't know where to start and we're
filming a fear factor episode at tone
ranch says 270,000
acre ranch in the middle of the country
while middle of the state rather.
And they were saying that they have a
wild pigs there and they would teach you
how they.
That was something that I had considered
before I met rinella and when I met
rinella he took me on a hunt for his tv
show and I shot a mule deer and we ate
it that night.
Over the fire.
And I said that's it.
That's it.
The quote,
the cool part about hunting is a,
nothing goes to waste.
So I take,
I take the hides to a guide to have them
stand.
So I've actually made a knife roll
out of one of the highlights.
I have an apron out of one of the hides.
My wedding ring has antler in it.
Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
I'm proud of that one.
That's crazy.
Um,
and yeah,
and I use all the bones to make a stock.
And then when I,
you know,
a lot of the cuts and one of the reasons
I want to write this book is to teach
hunters how to use those tough cuts.
One of my favorite parts of uh,
of the deer and different animals as the
neck and the neck has got all this
really super flavorful kind of
gelatinous meet kind of in between the
cartilage and stuff like that.
Uh,
and you make a stew with that stuff and
it is unbelievably tasty.
And,
you know,
I think in a lot of guys when they go
hunting,
they kind of breast out the birds and
they leave the little legs and they
don't really know that,
you know,
how to cook the legs of a Turkey or a
duck.
And um,
so that's one of the reasons why I want
to write this book and really educate
people how to use those tougher cuts
that you can be kind of tricky to cook
with.
Nela has a couple of good books on that
and one of the things that he's really
into his making shanks and also gluco
good brazing.
So good.
Yeah.
And he's also,
you know,
a big advocate of not wasting anything.
That's why he's into organ meat.
Liver.
And we had a fire that night.
Oh,
so good.
I had a Turkey feathers in my little
boot near,
on my wedding day from a Turkey.
Yeah,
it was neat.
It was really cool.
It's one of the reasons why it's so kind
of crazy that you're the guy that they
picked on and not the butcher shop
across the street or not some burger
joint down the street that's getting
factory farmed meat is you do have a
respect and appreciation for the
wildlife,
but that this ideological battle,
ground battle ground on their side,
it doesn't leave any room for forgiving
in.
there's no room for reasons just you're
either an animal murderer or a year that
the most amazing person ever because
you're vegan,
go vegan.
You know,
it's,
it's a really.
It's a new thing in terms of first world
problems,
first world countries.
I mean people have been needing
vegetarian dishes forever,
but in terms of like being ideologically
rabid about your,
you know,
your position,
this is,
this is very new.
It's within the last couple of decades.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's unfortunate because we're getting,
you know,
we've had a lot of support from our
community and Canada and the
international community and we're
actually getting support from other
vegans and vegetarian people writing to
us and say,
hey.
Yeah.
The same like,
hey,
these aren't our beliefs,
we're really sorry what you're going
through.
Um,
you know,
you have our support and it's a,
some of our customers are actually vegan
and they come for like vegetarian
risotto and like mushroom risotto that
they know or like,
you know,
really cool wild mushrooms that you
can't buy in the store.
So it's a,
you know,
it is unfortunate.
It is kinda,
it's kinda sad.
But uh,
you know,
we're,
we're just gonna continue,
you know,
being who we are and hopefully that,
uh,
you know,
like none of them have actually come in
for dinner,
you know,
of course they're not going to your up
here in the front window,
man,
a fucking murderer.
Um,
so there's,
you're right in the middle of this right
now,
which is kind of interesting to talk to
us about us.
It's not like after fact it's all going
down right now going on there.
They're,
you know,
they're coming back weekly.
Um,
but it's,
it's kind of at this point,
it's like dinner and a show like people
want to see it.
People are requesting the window window
table.
Well guess what,
fans,
this podcast,
you're going to want a front row seat
and it's going to be.
These are just a lot of freaks out there
listening to this that are going to want
to be there for the freak show.
Well toronto,
it's only about an hour and a half drive
from,
uh,
from buffalo at the border.
So it's a negative cross.
He fucks take a flight if you're into
the cold,
is there anything else you'd like to
tell people?
Like what is your website?
How can people go and check it out?
So antler kitchen,
bar.com
is his website.
There it is.
Pull that,
scroll down jimmy.
So you could see a look at some of that
yummy murder that.
So that deer dish does.
Cool.
Yeah,
you put a skull on the table with all
that.
So that,
that platter,
that shukui potters,
all the meat from that deer and the
terrain on the side,
the little square piece was actually
meet from that skull.
So I braise that skull a,
turn the meat into a terrain from the
tongue in the cheek and then serve.
That was actually at the game dinner
that a newspaper did.
When are you heading back to toronto?
Friday.
So I'm hearing visiting with family and
then um,
did you have access to a freezer?
Yes.
I have two commercial freezers in the
back.
I want to give you some elk.
Oh dude,
that is amazing.
Thank you for that.
Thank you so much.
It's an honor man.
I'll cook it with my dad this week.
Please do take pictures and I'll put it
up on instagram.
One hundred percent.
Awesome.
Before I love.
We love it,
right?
So yeah.
And their kitchen and the kitchen
bar.com
at 100 staff at [inaudible] kitchen bar,
all that kind of stuff you can find.
What is your instagram?
My instagram is at the hunter.
Chef.
Okay.
Thanks man.
There's a lot of fun.
I,
you so much.
I hope this all works out and all angry
vegans.
Please just,
I,
I know where you're coming from,
but you really.
This is the wrong fight.
It really is.
There's the battle is factory farming.
That's the real battle ground and this
is the wrong.
This is like the most ethical version of
what you're opposing and I think
there's,
there's a,
there's a healthy comfortable middle
ground for the 99 percent that aren't
fucking idiots.
I really do and I hope we can find it.
Thank you.
Alright fuckers.
Be nice to each other by.